the Joe Rogan experience I love how much
the bantamweight division has heated up
it's been such a crazy ride for myself
and just being a part of this and being
able to see like the wave and
generations of different fighters coming
in and out you know I you know I was
talking about it like El Nino you know
Gilbert Melendez is seen like when he
was on the top and now he's kind of like
his fight last fight with our nylons
kind of like you could kind of see like
the passing of the guard or maybe maybe
he's just not a because I know heap
office tower some type of P do so so
maybe that was something to do with it
or maybe 35 I think or six yeah in
Arnold Allen's 25 and [ __ ] nasty
young bull yeah and he's being trained
by Feroz AHA be who I mean I don't think
there's anybody better yeah in terms of
trainers I think there's like just as
good or in the neighborhood of good but
he's the [ __ ] man as far as I'm
concerned yeah and there's a lot of just
a lot of hot prospects she's coming out
and you got the quarry stayin hey gains
even over here I know Rivera lost two
fights in a row now but he still as
tough as they come he was beating PT on
until he got dropped that yup grounds
one and two he won round three even
having his nose busted up and everything
Petrey on though man he is a seasoned
striker it's really interesting to see
him with a guy like Jimmy who relies on
his power and his toughness and you know
his bulldog tenacity to see him get lit
up in those two rounds so Shion just set
traps and look for openings then when he
finally found them he just called her
Aksum yeah I mean it's a really exciting
division right now
real exciting that might be my next
fight though him for the belt I would
hope I would think that would be the
next fight and I kind of liked that
matchup he actually tried to Punk me at
the u.s. CPI Center last week it was
kind of it was funny at the same time I
was like dude I'm not really
understanding and then on my left side I
got I'm getting worked on I got unica
skaia
whatever her name is she's on my left
side and she's getting worked on and
then I didn't know there were teammates
so he comes in he's at the mirror he's
doing like the thumb things like
slashing his throw I start busting out
laughing and I show him the Bell and I
start slashing my throat I'm like yeah
I'm you know I'm gonna get the strat
whatever so he comes in he comes in with
this camera crew and it starts to go a
little bit back and forth but I can't
understand he doesn't really speak
English right so
I guess he said something and then she
translated out of nowhere so I'm like
I'm getting ganged up on right now and
it she's like he says why are you afraid
to fight him in Moscow and I was like
whoa what did I just come from but yeah
I look back at him like no one tells him
no one's afraid to fight him and then I
thought I thought about I was like wait
[ __ ] who's ranked higher you
don't call the shots I call the shots
I was like you're not dealing away
you're not Sean Shelby you fight where I
said you're gonna fight or wherever Dana
says we're gonna fight so don't don't
stay here to try to like act like I'm
everyone's afraid to fight him like what
I don't want to go to Moscow to fight
that's one uh he lives in I thinks he's
from Siberia Oh from what I know but I
know he trains tiger muy Thai okay
that's right so he trains in Thailand
and he lives or he's from the coldest
most dangerous part of the world great
yeah I'm not looking to go there and
fight there guy I'm like I mean if I
have to I will
is there a Moscow card scheduled there
was talking's of it and I think November
Oh upcoming yeah yeah oh wow cool
experience but it's not it's not an
ideal thing for me in terms of financial
situation getting out there paying a tax
is I'm like dude this just I just rather
be home not you know somewhere logged
yeah like I don't give a [ __ ] where he
find him in the [ __ ] bathroom I would
have for him into PI Center if he was
acting you know if he if he deserved it
but it is what it is I'm like dude no
one's afraid you I'm a fighter I don't
understand when fighters try to
intimidate fighters and make it look
like every fight in a cage
right you know it's like dude but it
does work the thing is like [ __ ] with
people's heads is real yeah this is true
let it's true like the best example
chose they all was one of the greatest
fighters of all time yeah I really
believe that he was out of his composure
when he fought Connor and that's one of
the reason why charged after Connor and
Connor cracked him with that straight
left so like Connor was in his head that
he was working in the back room when he
was like that's unreal unreal unreal I
mean he planned it out he knew it was
coming it's like Maz Badal practicing
that flying knee against Askren it's
really similar yeah it's like you know
tendencies and you also know emotions
and he just wanted to get at Connor so
bad yeah and yet Connor knew he was
coming so you like give him some faint
hop around throw some side kicks hop
knows he's coming back and as he's
coming catches something perfect isn't
coming in well against similar because
they're both coming at each other yeah
charging in and get caught crazy car
crash but I don't think I don't know if
he really thinks he's gonna intimidate
me I I don't know if that's what he
thinks or he's trying it that it's a
time-honored proven tactic yeah get
inside someone's head they get angry and
one of two things happens either they
[ __ ] you up more because now they're
really personal you know like like Maz
Badal yeah or it bothers them and they
lose some people lose genuinely lose
their composure if they don't like a
fighter yeah you know that I used to
have I'd say that cowboy and Nate Diaz
that was an insane fight and that was a
thing that's last time he probably ever
let himself get mad he said so I was a
learning experience you know he realized
that like that [ __ ] talk and [ __ ] with
his head and you know but there's some
guys who do better when they should talk
yeah
[Applause]